[Applause]
oh you can perfect
[Music]
what's up guys I am Thomas dobiziola
whatever you want to call me I'm here
with my co-host Marty O'Neal what's up
guys what's up this is the dope as usual
podcast we're here to talk about life
problems drugs accomplishments and
everything in between I'm super excited
today today's an episode that many
people have asked for and it's finally
here this is the Travis Thompson come on
man thanks for being here thank you for
having me but first off dev's up to the
game oh wait it was crazy
yeah that's but that's not like Cali
skater [__] 100 you know so that's like
that skate parking that's exactly where
I got it from in Seattle
is like this like that and he says
that's too much gangbangers
hey man I'm just out the way you feel me
no I have a lot of homies do this one oh
yeah that's like that's like the
southeast yeah like I don't know that's
not my price it's not my business though
little handshakes is kids
wishing bro I see though I see the
rappers on stage with their DJ
[__] we need one choreographed
yeah it would be kind of tired me and my
boys used to slap each other out with
the left hand only to each other though
so you'd walk in a room hit everybody up
with the right hand but then only us
with the left oh that's like taboo but
just for y'all that's like doing the
Satan like
exactly it's like taboo but damn that's
the homies though put the [__] out of
your finger too you smack that oh yeah
you gotta hit the cool snaps
you know I had a snap the other day and
someone's like oh a little white boy hit
the snap I was like I don't know man hey
yeah it comes with a territory exactly
um real quick those pictures I sent you
can you just pop them up real quick so
um before we started we talked about it
the reason I found you is because
everybody's like yo is this your brother
ago
what the hell because I used to have the
same hair like the same hair bro I know
so um I just want to show everybody real
quick that we don't look alike at all oh
is this is a two photos of us
saw this picture and go uh
I hear you yo there's a picture no but
that's what I was just saying bro it's
been fun to watch like you and this
other kid named young Jeff people always
tag us together so it's like I've
watched you guys Ascension just through
like getting tagged on Instagram and
then when I finally got tapped in I'm
like oh this [__] is hard you guys are
really doing something different same
thing I said I'm like this guy does look
like me his music's sick yeah
come on
oh God
yo what's up
I pop it up on the screen but my whole
High School this exact same haircut
though yeah you saw it Rosie was like if
you had a Hollister hoodie on I wouldn't
have even thought twice
no I had one nice [__] hella funny bro
yeah no if I got a tan and you can you
let your chick grow bro come on 100 yeah
hell yeah um I know you smoking stuff I
know we're not there a nice guy clock
yet how far are we I thought we
oftenized are we are we smart yes bro
that's what I need bro I ran I brought
like a whole quarter yesterday and I oh
my God yes you have a lighter right next
to you also let's go what are we smoking
what is this this one is called it's
look it it was ugly and I'm like this is
the one you're saying it's the fire he
goes I swear to God and I out of all the
people at the spot I go this dude Zack
is the snob like a wood smoking because
honestly that blue petrol it's the
ugliest weed ever but it's so gas it was
blowing all right well then we'll try
blue petrol never heard about that yeah
for real that other blue petrol I gotta
imagine it's like in the ocean yes I was
smoking I was smoking bowls let me just
use that letter go ahead oh yeah go
first go first I see your you guys are
joint people that's how I know you
really smoke I'm Still A backwood Guy oh
but I'm I'm in like frontos and loose
and [__] but I'm trying to phase out
you're in the cold exactly is that is
that what it is
but I don't know but that's what I only
smoke joints when it's like sunny out
really I swear to God cause like on a
sunny day I like land in L.A and I'm
like get to my BNB and I roll up I'm
like oh let me roll the paper up because
it feels more it feels like I don't know
I got the breezes for the sun is hitting
me I like what you're saying but when
I'm home and it's like windy and cold
out I want to like curl up in my head
it's like a blanket you feel me
Burns for a whole hour yeah I'm not rich
enough to be smoking big ass joints like
this all [__] today like but the
backwards are so expensive they are
expensive bro but I've been on the
fronto and the loose leaf lately okay
and then and the zemies you [__] the
zimmies you ever heard of the zemies
z-e-m-i-s I don't know but some neutrals
there's some Sacramento kids was rapping
about it so I seen it at the store and I
was like oh let me go [__] with this
[__] and it's hot bro it's like
definitely way too harsh I like people
hit that [__] and they go oh my what is
you doing bro paper bag status yeah it's
a little but yeah now I'm a tobacco
addict I gotta relax yeah I used to
smoke number swishers and white owls but
I remember [__] told me he was
like if you only smoke weed in blunts
you don't really love the weed that's
how I feel I gotta be honest and you
know bro it's not lying bro yeah and
it's yeah it's not it's not the same
experience bro you feel me shout out to
all the Backwoods smokers though if you
like it you like it some people just eat
tobacco they just like tobacco they're
really skinny little backwood Blunts and
[__] or they rolling fat ass backwards
for no reason I hate that [__] you hate
a [__] yeah no I like a good little
one point five in the in the backwood or
something and I cut the backwood down so
it's not too much oh so it's like right
here it's like a square it looks like a
paper damn near when I cut it because
some people was just big ass black
because you don't know how to roll so
you roll a big ass blunt it's easy and
of some boo fast weed do you feel me
like yeah yeah that backward [__] is
kind of out now what about bong rips and
dabs see my lady is a bong rip person uh
the bong is sitting on the but like I
said like I need the tobacco damn near I
need the and there's something about you
don't want the weed without the tobacco
I hit a bong rip if I'm like it's like 3
A.M and I'm away can I go take a piss
I'll be like yeah let me hit some weed
before I go back to bed but like I don't
know the bong it feels like Diet weed to
me sometimes you need all right I'm
disrespectful I know I know that's crazy
I know yeah I'll get you a bong man okay
let's go come on I love it I know I need
to you guys are like organic like real
smokers though I'm like a rapper
you smoke what you smoke man yeah
um
What's it gonna say the ball rips sorry
Eric caught off track I got caught up
trap oh before we started you asked me
where I'm from and I said Fresno I go
well by Merced and you knew I know where
I know where that is hell yeah bro I
mean [__] I'm I'm a West Coast baby so
like I've been following you know
thizzler obviously yeah they post like
ghetto boy from Merced he was part of a
rap group with uh this kid named
Babyface wood from Yakima from where
you're at uh yeah well Eastern I'm from
like Seattle like Western Washington
Eastern Washington like three hours away
there's a city called Yakima and that's
where bro is from you know I'm saying
they're in a rap group together I
thought Red Alert that happened hey the
the the the the the ties the rest
that's not my business though no you
know what I'm saying not at all Sizzler
does such a great job on Instagram
that [__] is tight bro like they putting
a lot of West Coast kids on but I find
like all these West Coast artists I
listen to Bro at your board of Ray
Seattle I'm born what's it called I was
I was born in Seattle but then I moved
up to Dutch Harbor Alaska so like yeah
bro Dutch Hardware a lot like in the
very corner like where they filmed
deadliest catching [__] like yeah I was
there until I was like six and then I
moved back to Seattle and then my
family's from the Navajo reservation in
Arizona so we would just go back and
[__] like that but yeah so man it's I'm
a Seattle kid though yeah no sh okay so
you're from Seattle you moved to Alaska
would you see a bunch of bears and yeah
well no here's the thing bro it's like
that's like Anchorage and like Juno and
[__] like I was in Dutch Harbor which is
straight fishing and I'm I was only
there because my parents are chefs the
chefs they're chefs so you see it but
you see it my boy
yeah they're both worships yeah that's
how that's how they met they was working
at like hotels in Seattle like chefing
together yeah but uh what's it called
mood up because they were chefs at the
galley which is where all the fishermen
would eat so I was just like a little
restaurant baby until I was like six you
know I mean it was it was fire bro
because that's like I was eating like
fur and like in Nigeria and like like
video tacos and [__] when I was like a
little ass kid bro you feel me like
cultured
closer do you feel me so like it was
fire bro like yeah I loved Alaska but at
the same time like it's you can't it's
not sustainable bro you can't live there
for real no yeah at least in Dutch
Harbor bro players you only live there
to work you feel me but like
anchorageville it's one of my favorite
cities in the world to play It's like a
city yeah Anchorage is bro it's lit I'm
telling you bro you can you can stay out
till 6 a.m and get like a lobster roll
from the bar bro I'm telling you bro the
sun's out right the Sun never goes down
brother oh that's it gets dust at like
midnight and then it comes back up yo
that would drive me insane it would well
I remember being a little kid we had we
didn't have blinds on the apartment so
we were putting blankets on we were like
nailing blankets on the Windows because
it's the sun wouldn't go down for months
so yeah you're a little imagine being
like a little baby too you don't know
when to sleep
because
I was just up at 4am all the time bro
just like doing dumb [__] running around
the apartment buildings and fishermen
and [__] telling you bro it's lit up
there are you only child right now I got
an older sister but she's like six seven
years older so that's like hold it you
know how that goes it's like but that's
why it's cool though like me and my
sister never beef about nothing because
she's like young ass up like you know
what I'm saying like you feel me it's
cool it's cool damn okay Alaska and then
you said Navajo reservation reservation
that's in Northeast Arizona if I'm
native for real I mean yeah
wait he's Mexican though yeah yeah in my
book you native
like Albuquerque New Mexico like two
hours outside Brooklyn New Mexico yeah
so like yeah so that's like home too
what's that like man I ain't like I
ain't gonna lie like I I'm a I'm an off
the res Indian you feel me so like I
would I go for summer [__] and then they
come up for summer shits but it's like
it's hella different bro it's just like
the boonies the desert
but I don't know it's like it's like
rich in culture and tradition but at the
same time it's like not much going on
out there bro like it's really it's hard
for my family to find jobs you feel me
like I'm posting on Instagram like hey
yo who on the Reds got work type [__]
you feel me but Brandon Thompson got a
trash service now that you can go in
Fort Defiance Arizona please go tap in
with her but yeah yeah Russia it's just
it's not much going on out there but
like yeah it's like I go every year to
visit my family and we usually play a
show there every year like on the
fairgrounds yeah so when you go into a
reservation
I've never even seen the thing is you
probably had but you didn't know the
town the thing is you probably well
they're different everywhere you go oh
so like in in Washington there's hella
there's like there's Eastern Washington
reservations whether it's like a desert
where it reminds me of Arizona but then
there's there's reservations just
outside the city where you can like go
there's amphitheaters where you can see
[__] Nickelback perform type [__]
yeah
yeah you feel me like like there's some
races with casinos and some residents
but not it with like they don't got like
you feel me like my rest has like a
Walmart 30 minutes from the crib and
like and and an Applebee's and like so
in some like a Taco Bell and a Sonic and
[__] but at the same time you call 9-1-1
like my mom my Grandma had to call 9-1-1
no one showed up for like an hour bro
you call 9-1-1 it gives you to another
it's directs you do another line
I'm telling you bro it's like so but
it's hard though because I hate talking
about it sometimes because I don't want
to like only like say the negative say
the negative you feel me because like
sometimes like I went on Sway and I had
a bunch of like native activists people
be like why like the poorest of the poor
well like I do I grew up like and I'm
like bro my family lives in a house too
I'm like you know what I'm saying I know
what we're like bro like what but at the
same time like there's I don't know it
still feels very underrepresented and
under explained okay especially on
videos especially on media platforms
like this you feel me so like but at the
same time like I don't know the res is
different everywhere but it's beautiful
and it's I don't know we've been
delegated or dealt a shitty hand do you
feel me so yeah in Buffalo it's
different than the ominous it all
depends on the city oh for Shelly though
yeah
bro there's reservations in every state
in America I had no [__] idea about
that yeah bro like I've never been
talked about it I stopped in Arizona to
get gas once and I'm like damn Mexican
guy got braids oh he's he's a native
I hear you bro like even in like Seattle
bro like they pushed the native super
far south or super far north so if
you're in the city of Seattle you might
like every street name and every part of
Seattle Seattle's named after chief
South who's a native every street in
Washington or city is a Native American
name you feel me but you [__]
would never know you know what I'm
saying even when I'm down here in La you
can see you can see a little [__] like
that or in Arizona but yeah man it's
just one of them things where you got to
start talking about this [__] so
everyone sees the world in a different
way I had no idea man yeah bro well it
was like that too Lackawanna Cheektowaga
Tonawanda
exactly those are exactly bro I don't
even think about if they go to Seattle
it's like Mukilteo Puyallup you know
what I'm saying like Yakima like I'm
saying it's all like natives in Japan
bro it's a cool way to grow up though
and it feels rare on some rap [__] too
like when I walk in the buildings people
oh wait for real like what what damn
they want to know so like it's a
blessing in a way for me yeah I've never
heard of Native American rapper in my
whole career hey man I mean yeah that's
a that's a damn shame but at the same
time like I completely understand yeah
no you heard of another there's there's
definitely hell yeah bro there's there's
a few who are killing [__] right now
obviously there's like Superman and like
this kid named rescos Griz I promise
y'all Rez Coast Grizz I love that name
bro he on some like juice World [__] and
he looked like my cousin or something
bro like he's fresh he's saying like
there's like the snotty nose Rez kids
and [__] like bro I'm telling you like
natani means like Tia wood like there's
there's native artists out here killing
it and there's like uh there's classic
Native American bands [__] that
[__] won't even like come and
get your love that's a Native American
band bro I didn't know that exactly bro
like yeah how did the Native American
side of your family feel about weed
growing up uh oh they man they they lit
man they lit hell yeah I mean my Dad
what's it called he was a drinker for a
while but he stopped and [__] like he
got sober and [__] when I was a kid and
like he'll hit the weed and [__] every
now and then now when we like on a
camping trip are we in a new city or
something like we was in Europe and we
was in Amsterdam at one of them cafes
and I my dad like reaches for the weed
I'm like what the [__] is he do it hey
everybody you know what I'm saying so
and they're cool my mom is lit too like
she they're they're they my mom hid the
weed for me forever bro like I didn't I
was hiding weed from her she was hiding
weed from me I didn't know she smoked
until like I started rapping bro stop it
I swear to God because I was I was
rapping about this weed [__] and then
she like sits that she sits down and
she's like why why are you lying I'm
like what she's like why are you trying
to be something you not I was like what
are you talking about she's like you
don't smoke weed and I was like oh Mom
like I've been smoking weed since I was
like a little ass kid just grounded now
you feel me and she was like oh well I
smoke weed I was like what the [__] and
my mom is like a Christian lady you know
what I'm saying like oh so it's shocking
so it to me it was shocking to my sister
and my aunties and [__] that was like
look at this kid like tied in his weed
thinking he hard as [__] knowing and
then I learned who my mom was and who my
dad was you know I'm saying like they
was lit they was out here you feel me
that's awesome when this happened I was
like 19 18 19 you feel me so I was we
were hiding away from each other you
know what I'm saying but I would I would
smell it thinking it was my I'm like
where did I where did I put this weed
not knowing it's my mom
she hates when I be talking about this
[__] because she think her church
friends is gonna judge her or something
and I'll be like man [__] them friends
bro like it's weed it's not that deep
Bro
and we did like a cut video where she
admitted she like drank a little beer
while like uh she was pregnant and the
comments was like oh my God she was like
take it down she could have yeah she lit
though that's my they're hella
supportive bro and they're cool they're
regular ass folks you feel me like it's
tight it's awesome to hear yeah bro
they're cool it's a good upbringing to
have as a rapper you feel me because
some rappers like their parents don't
even know they rap so they sell out a
show
you know what I'm saying my parents was
like on it early taking me to shows as
like a kid you know I'm saying like my
dad's been taking me to shows forever
what kind of shows like Rock shows local
rap shows like my parents I think my
first date was a reggae show you know
what I'm saying yeah yeah so they're
just I grew up with like no one really
made music but it was just we loved
music so yeah
man it's so weak bro it's embarrassing
week worse than yours you're not even
gonna know it too it's like this girl
named Stacy Eureka she had a couple
random hits she played the Puyallup Fair
you feel me but the first concert that I
like you chose to I chose to go to was
probably like a Blue Scholars Macklemore
show back in Seattle like just because I
was a super big Seattle hip-hop fan as a
little kid like when I was like 13 14
like I was a kid in a backpack like at
the show like trying to meet people
trying to like listen to people rap when
they did the little ciphers and [__] and
like eventually when I was in high
school I started a podcast so I could
like you did hell yeah bro I was like
bro I had a pie cold it was kind opposed
to the podcast it's still on Soundcloud
bro I swear to God bro like because yeah
I was gonna spoken with poetry and [__]
yeah so I did I I started a podcast too
because I want to be a rapper how do I
meet the scene bro because I'm at these
shows but I'm a little ass kid bro how
do I meet people yeah I was like well
everyone wants to do an interview like
everyone just feel like they want to
talk about themselves like [__] it then
we just start a podcast and this was
early bro this was 2013 2014. they had
to be a long time ago I'm telling you
bro this was like RSS fees where like
just people were just learning what that
[__] was you know
[__] Marc Maron and like you know
what I'm saying it was wild bro I feel
like early on that [__] bro but yeah I
had a podcast and [__] that's how I
started rapping and like that's how I
got in the scene really that's how I met
all this yeah bro I swear to God man I'm
a hustler man I'm a hustling damn I
couldn't even imagine because you you
look like
how many times people ask you are you
you're 17. oh hey I get carded at them
everywhere I get card at the movie
theater I'm trying to get beers
[Laughter]
bro yeah I'm still getting Carter for
Backwoods and everything bro if I try
sometimes I try to buy like NyQuil or a
lighter or something like a gardener
yeah bro I'm telling you bro it's wild
you got the sleeve though that kind of
sucks yeah yeah that's kind of what like
at the bars now people usually kind of
let me slide now but yeah it's it's I
didn't have these tattoos until like
2020 19 I think yeah and then I got a
deal and I was like oh I have tattoo
money let me go crazy oh yeah oh yeah
and then again then you become a rapper
and then it gets expensive as [__]
but yeah is that all you got you got a
bunch of more I got I got like some legs
[__] and I got my chest and [__] I'm
trying to get more but every time I get
a tattoo I'm like who am I bro who do I
think I am bro this [__] hurts bro I am
not a hard body bro like every time I
sit down I'm like oh this [__] is I am
wincing bro and the older you get the
more it hurts yeah I said I got no one
because
I'm afraid of needles bro what was the
worst spot so far oh the chest bro the
chest like right here on your sternum
bro it's like it's like a jackhammer
right under your bone but that's like
right where you breathe so you're like
you have to move you're like bro I'm
telling you bro it's like that [__]
sucks I'm afraid that started hearing
like that super like super high arm like
almost armpit yeah like yeah bro
that [__] see what he just said I'm
afraid I'll start and go I'm out that's
kind of bro the thing is though I had
once you start on like an invisible spot
in the arm and it looks like it's part
of a sleeve it forces you to go like
look how goofy this I just got this at
Amsterdam because I didn't I haven't
done with this arm but I'm like [__] I
have to keep going because this [__]
look goofy as [__] just the hand and
that's adorable that's adorable
you feel me bro no hell yeah man yeah
that's funny so before we get off that
um you say growing up on the res is what
you called it and then I saw a little
article about you were on that the show
reservation of my sister oh yeah
oh hell yeah
so how'd that come about bro so like
like you said like like you said you
never heard of a Native American rapper
so it's not many bro like it's a small
community of us we really like we all
for the most part pretty [__] I'm
learning more of the Dynamics from how
it goes anyways but uh
they're off like everyone who worked on
that show Damian already knew who I was
there was a fan bro like they've been
tapped in for years like even the
Creator Sterling harjo like he's been
like he's no he's been known about it
and [__] like and the kids who were on
the show like the Pharaoh and like he
already knew about it and [__] like so
when I pulled up to set Bro like well
how did it happen my bad I'm getting
ahead of myself how it happened bro was
the show trailer comes out my dad is
like you got to do something with this
you got to get a song on here so that's
where my head was I need a song on this
show so for the whole first season I'm
blowing them up like if you need a song
anything you need from me Sterling bro I
got you you need a new song All song You
Wanna create a song like [__] it like
I'll do whatever and then after a while
like there I saw they posted they needed
extras for like the second season so I
just posted to my story and at this
point I have a hundred thousand
followers or whatever so we have a
little bit of a fan base I'm like it's
like tell these people you trying to see
me as an extra on the show yeah just
because I want them to keep my name in
there that has you finished and then
after like a week bro they like posted
that I mean they uh my DM talking about
they have an audition
and bro I I flip [__] bro I was like oh
my God it's like for a real role but
like what the [__] I thought it was like
a one-line thing they sent me it's like
a big character in the episode and [__]
I was like okay bet so I was just
watching YouTube auditions and like
YouTube videos all week trying to figure
out how to be an actor I did some [__]
over zoom and they [__] with it I
waited like two months and then like I
got a call like you want to come to
Oklahoma in like three or four days I'm
like bruh what the [__] yeah bro hell
yeah and when I got there bro it was so
lit it was like the most supportive [__]
ever like they would treat me like the
rap star bro you feel me like they're
playing my songs for Marc Maron and [__]
he's just sitting there like listening
to my [__] like oh this is kind of hard
bro it's crazy bro like it was a trip
like and it went that Hulu [__] is
different bro they're coming around with
towels and fans like like on some
Superstar [__] a little baby water
bottle it's crazy bro being a fan yeah I
feel you now I realize that to have a
person come over from that with a Hulu
hat that's just spraying you with a fan
you only do that I feel like oh that's
how I keep doing this that's exactly
right at first
it's like that's weird and then after on
your second day you're like where's the
fan at like come on
yo that's sick as hell not for real
though and that show is Monumental bro
like that show is one like there's never
been a show about reservation kids you
feel me and that like I had a [__]
panic attack when it came out to like
I've opened Hulu and to watch it bro
like I was like oh damn this is forever
oh like rap [__]
is only as long as you want to make it
last but that [__] gonna sit on Hulu
forever did you see it before so I was
no I didn't see a damn thing oh no I saw
a trailer and I had like one little part
in the trailer so like I didn't I'm
sitting there with my with my girl my
sister like tweaking the [__] out I
paused him is it good is it good they're
like let us watch it calm the [__] down
and I'm like bro but yeah bro like that
[__] changed my life too like everywhere
I go people are like coming up to me
talking about it it's tight bro
it's an amazing opportunity bro that
show is amazing yeah and how did it go
on set in terms of like oh it was lit
bro like they were like those kids
aren't even acting those are some real
Res Kids bro those are some real like
they're hard body like they're gonna be
stars and [__] so I ain't even gonna
talk about all the [__] we was getting
into out in Tulsa yeah and [__] but like
bro we was we was really wild and
running around getting lit like catching
snakes on the side of the freeway like
on some reservation Oklahoma [__] Bro
shut up mama oh it's hard but yeah but
like snakes now for I swear to God on
some real [__] bro it's lit and yeah bro
like that the whole experience was fire
and like Tulsa is a crazy City like it's
dope people don't even know like Tulsa
is a film City like they're filming out
like they're filming hella movies out
there like when I was out there bro like
like Bill hader's parents were at the
coffee shop and they're they're like
let's build haters parents I'm like why
are Bill haters parents they're from
here they're like oh no but he films
here like he got a house I'm like what
the [__] bro like yeah there's hella
celebrities in Tulsa Oklahoma like on
the low yeah they're crazy and the
exactly bro on the yeah it's like the
wild west of weed out there right now
bro yeah bro and the but the food was
good the clubs and the Bars were popping
so shout out toaster bro the whole time
yeah reservation dogs was like
life-changing bro for real sick dude
yeah my sister watches it heavy I gotta
start no you gotta watch it bro you
gotta watch it bro it's a real show
about some reservation kids it's hard
bro oh boy
yeah
yeah and I didn't really have to like
even act they just wanted me to be
myself like I said I'm pretty sure I
said like hella I'm like bruh hella yeah
yo you know where somebody's from when
you see and you hear that [__] for sure
it's non-stop
what's that I say Hella too much damn
that was dumb
all right let's get into something real
quick I wanted to bring it up
I've heard your music I follow you yeah
you know you ever hear an artist and you
just go you know I don't think I've ever
watched more than like a music video let
me go watch some more [__] and you know
I know all these songs but I've never
seen the video weird yeah you know what
I'm saying like about so I went and
watched your videos right I was like you
know let me watch some more
there's a song in there I swear to God
bro I I thought you were nine years old
bro there's a horchata oh that's my very
first song ever bro that's my that's
your first one ever yeah but yes that's
my first song ever bro it was that's my
first time in the studio that was
awesome
yeah bro I was like I think I had just
graduated high school so I was 18. oh
dude I thought you were like four oh
yeah no I still look like a [__] 18
year old but like yeah bro like no when
I was yeah I was like I think I was just
graduated yeah that was insane wow I
thought you were in like just getting
out of Middle School bro yeah I know I
know bro and I just got a stupid ass
haircut like I just cut my hair I got a
haircut I got a dumb haircut but I cut
it shorter so I look like a super baby
and it's like super bowl cut it out bro
like oh man bro yeah no they should
change my life though that [__] like I
was working like a regular ass job and
then like out of nowhere one day that
[__] went up on Reddit
but then it was corny because people
were trying to say like a rapper from
Reddit did it I was like I'm not from
Reddit bro I didn't even have an account
till like six months ago bro but anyway
but like no that [__] went up on Reddit
and like started going crazy and like
that's what like led to a bunch of [__]
in Seattle and like starting to Bubble
for me bro it was great I love who did
the who thought of the video uh I came
up with the video with a shot by the
homie raffy bro it was one yeah I just
wanted the one take oh yeah the one
thing and I had the homies all lined up
and it's crazy because I also I still
kick it with like damn near most of
those people and everyone looks like a
[__] baby bro everyone else because I
damn you look the same when everyone
else has grown the [__] up so they like
it's insane it's one of my notes yeah
all the homies in the video stay the
same yeah all the same PS one of my
notes they're all the same people yeah
years and years ago by I'm like yeah
that's what I'm saying bro I'm telling
you bro everything we do is super
homegrown and like I was independent for
a while signed a deal and I'm back
independent again like and even when we
were on the label it was like I had it
was a super independent style deal like
and with everything we do is in-house
and like you feel me like the homies
there's like that's what I'd be trying
to tell people bro like there's
greatness in the homies if you like
nurture it and like really look for it
but also you gotta find the ones that
are for real for Shelly because yeah no
it's like super draining to like watch
wasted potential yeah it's the worst
especially you know I'm telling you bro
like it could be your downfall too
that's what I'm saying that [__] will
kill you that should have really like
that's why you say yeah
being from like a city like Seattle it's
hard to like I'll just watch people like
get in their head and like trick
themselves out of like cool positions
and I feel like and I only say that
because I've almost done that to myself
you feel me so like but it's it's really
frustrating to watch but I remember like
I remember I saw Rex like you know where
the Rex life Raj he's an artist from the
bed he's fired bro I was on I went on
tour with him this past year but I saw
him Seattle randomly he was we were at a
James Blake show and he didn't even tell
me he was in town we just bumped into
each other but he said he was like hey
bro like I feel like I can sense you
going through something right now but I
just from the outside looking in it
looks great so just keep it looking
great don't like don't fold publicly
because something's coming you know what
I'm saying and it was just one of those
moments where I'm like damn bro like you
ever you ever like realize I'm in a
position right now where everybody else
would have folded yeah you feel me yeah
but that's but those are the moments
where I feel like actual magic happens
it's like okay now later it's like okay
now you now you have something now you
now I have a reason to root for you you
feel me like and that's kind of like you
for me that's what I get from when I
watch wasted potential type [__] like
I'm like oh like I can't I can't dwell
on like little [__] like that because
that or like the homies I can't worry
about the homies you know what I'm
saying cause like we have a mission you
know I'm saying we're on a mission and
we got to make this [__] look good you
feel me I love the way you put that come
on bro I've been dealing with a lot of
that so no I hear you bro that's how it
goes bro especially if I mean I know
what I've heard of what Merc said is
like I know what type of [__] be out
there bro like it's it's just draining
bro it's very draining but like yeah
like I said bro
you can't trick yourself out of position
like you [__] are blessed
you don't got time to worry about none
of that [__] I love the way you're
putting it bro weeks ago I just started
going I can't worry no more I got it
real life I got [__] to do I got so much
to do I got to do it also I kind of
believe we have one lighter yeah this is
crazy no this is a crazy show
motherfucker's gonna be like look at
them
bowls I left them over there and I
didn't want to get up during the episode
when we change the camera so I'm just
grab a lighter you know I'll be I'll be
sick that's hella funny um so hold on
the video I love the [__] video after
it goes on Reddit you start catching a
little bit of traffic right yeah and
then what happens you're 18 19 you're
working on where I'm 18 19 I'm working
at uh I'm working no no my first job was
Old Navy and I was when I was 16 then I
worked at a pizza place but then when I
was really rapping like during that time
I was working at Charlie's Produce you
ever heard of Charlie's Produce it's
just like I'd be seeing the trucks in La
so I'm in California sometimes but uh
it's just like a produce company that
like ships food like produce and food to
boats and grocery stores and restaurants
you know I was I was in a warehouse with
like crackheads
and just like mean ass like old ladies
and just like repackaging fruit and
vegetables it was like that was the most
depressing time in my life bro because
it was like 5 a.m to like three or four
P.M every day and if my mom worked in
the office so I was like yes slack off
at all you can't slack off at all and
like and it's a young you and you're a
young man working in a warehouse full of
old people you grab the pallets and they
find out you're a rapper so they like
you need to wrap the palettes in like
like so they go they go hey trap hey
trap you the rapper
hey bro every every [__] day every
day bro that [__] pissed me you know so
I just seen this [__] from at
the deli or something he was just like
hey I used to work at Charlie's I was
like hey yo tell the homies [__] them
bro they call me Macklemore they was
like they come wrap these Palace yeah
bro like that was like but that's what
turned me up though that's so that's
when I was like I'm at that job also
having like a million views on YouTube
like this is [__] bro like this is
some [__] you feel me and then after
that I got a job at a preschool when I
was like 20 21 through what I was a para
educator
it was lit so it's like you're like a
teacher's assistant to like like split
special ed and like what I don't know
what like regular learning or whatever
it's called but like that was the best
job bro because you got summer break
with pay winter break with pay like you
only work from 8 A.M to 3 P.M every day
and you're just watching kids and like
it was it was I I put on like three or
four rap homies like in Seattle to like
work being para Educators because it is
so fire it was like the best job I loved
it but yeah what other job do you get a
full break but what exactly what I'm
telling you with pay it's active right
so shout out to the para Educators man
but anyways I'm a para educator and I'm
like 2021 McLemore takes me on tour
like right when I turned 21 I turned 21
on tour yeah yeah so like yeah he takes
me on tour and like I think right end of
2017 in the 2017. for his Gemini tour
and I was on this song called corner
store and we did Fallon and [__] and I
at that time I had only had probably
like two three thousand followers but I
go on tour I come home with like 20. and
I'm like my tune core checks are
starting to like get match my preschool
job so I'm getting like double pay so
I'm like oh [__] I actually kind of have
like I have more than 300 in my pocket
at one time you know what I'm saying
like this is lit and
I go on tour I come back from tour I
realize they're gonna let me go when the
school year is over like I'm done oh and
I was like okay well I'm gonna be I got
all the rest of Summer pay like let me
just go crazy like and just double down
all through 2018 put out this mixtape
called you good and uh went on my own
headlining tour and like yeah bro like
2018 is when I like decided to like
really become a rapper for real and like
[__] started going crazy like I'm saying
in 2019 I signed a deal we did the BT
Cipher and [__] you know what I'm saying
like all this crazy wilding out all this
crazy [__] and then 20 pandemic happens
2021 I'm just I'm just rattling through
all this [__] but like yeah like I put
that album called Boulevard Boulevard
boy changing my life again you know what
I'm saying like so yeah and now and then
we left the label now I'm back
independent and it's like we're about to
go on a run so it's it's like really
tight bro like it feels good
what's up guys we want to take a quick
break from this episode to shout out our
longest standing sponsor you know it
it's manscaped talk a lot here on the
podcast about self-care and grooming
it's summer last thing your girl wants
to do is reach down and find a set of
sweaty balls do her a favor do yourself
a favor we're coming in hot this summer
with the crop mop guys you might be
looking at me wondering why my
confidence is so high and I'm not gonna
lie to you it's the crop preserver groin
deodorant and the crop preserve or groin
spray it's got me peeking right now so
you can join the 8 million men worldwide
enjoying manscape by going to
manscape.com Yola and getting 20 off
plus free shipping on your order whether
we're talking about devouring your pubes
with a lawnmower 4.0 and the performance
package 4.0 the finest nose and ears
hair trimmer on the market manscape's
got you covered across the board once
again you want to support the show you
want to feel good about yourself clean
those pubes up head over to manscape.com
Yola get yourself a 20 off discount plus
free shipping support the podcast and
our longest standing ad partner it's
manscaped from the gas pump to the
grocery store utility bills to streaming
services inflation is everywhere but
thankfully mint mobile is out there to
help ease the pain of inflation as the
first company to offer premium wireless
service directly online only mint mobile
allows you to start your plan from home
you can sign up at home and they have
way better rates with plans starting at
just 15 a month by going online mint
mobile has eliminated that cost of the
retail store those savings go directly
to the customer they go right to you
unlimited talk and text high-speed data
delivered on the nation's biggest 5G
Network so to take advantage of this
right now go to mintmobile.com forward
slash Yola and that's going to let you
get this deal starting at 15 a month
remember mintmobile.com forward slash
Yola and that's going to allow you to
get this deal for 15 a month you can
have every single thing that anyone else
has I I would go that route you could
switch over if you have any Services you
don't lose your contacts you'll lose
your phone number everything stays the
same all you're doing is switching
services and saving money mintmobile.com
forward slash Yola that's going to allow
you to get this deal starting at 15 a
month thank you mint mobile for
supporting the podcast back to the
episode
you get asked to go on tour where
exactly are you standing when you get
the call text or email because I know
you know well so my my man started
engineering for him so like he was
recording him and putting my music in
his ear that's how it happened and then
uh we do the song
I I'm just I they the homie tells me
they're talking about it they've been
like brought up me for tour because it's
already sold out so that's not like they
need any help for with from a big artist
they're like we could just bring
somebody local who are we gonna bring
and
I was bugging them because I just wanted
to know I want to go into ours are they
taking me are they taking me are they
taking me and eventually one day that
was like yo yeah you're coming on the
whole US tour plus you're playing Key
Arena in Seattle which is like where the
sonics played and [__] like that's like
it bro yeah
exactly you feel me but
yeah bro that where am I standing I
think I was in the car going to like
Guitar Center I think in Seattle when we
got the call we're going on tour bro
like and that's the that's all the
validation you like that was the first
time we got like oh [__] I'm a rapper
type validation yeah besides like
because a million streams is like
definitely a little bit of bread don't
get me wrong it's good money but and
like YouTube views is cool like the
AdSense money is cool but like you're
still not that's not a living bro so
like once I got a a tour it was like oh
[__] this is I could be something you
know what I'm saying and yeah definitely
like Turn Me Up on another level to like
I don't know keep going crazy yeah first
show
first show ever not even sure yeah first
thing you did by yourself as Travis
Thompson like the first thing you ever
did because you put out yourself like my
own headliner as just a show no your
your first show that's you you're the
headliner that's just you oh okay bet so
I threw a show in Seattle at the
crocodile back bar for like 100 people
it was like right at the end of high
school and oh [__] right at the end so
yeah that was like right when it was
like when archada and [__] was out okay
yeah yeah yeah so uh we sold it out and
I think it was like 100 people
and granted there's probably like 50
friends but it was the first time I'd
seen random people in my life like come
to a show and like once you do that in
Seattle like you can start getting
booked for stuff if you have like some
ticket history so it was like that was
like the night if I felt like I got
inducted into like Seattle rap it was
like I've sold out like 100 tickets and
people knew the words kinda
brought my mom on stage and [__] like
yeah bro like that [__]
that [__] is the [__] I think about all
the time though like that those moments
like when we saw people showing up from
those shows and [__] bro it's insane
like people have really like grown with
us because I don't got no hit songs for
real but like we have like catalog hits
that like people have tatted on their
[__] chest and [__] you know what I'm
saying like it's it's a it's a it's a
crazy thing you feel me oh
yeah as like what's that first show
because there had to be that night that
show was amazing bro yeah no that show
was like it the your headline shows are
easy bro I don't even get nervous for
headline shows no more because I'm like
bro these are my people
they showed up for me bro they like it's
a Thursday night in Nebraska and there's
a 150 people here and like to some
people that's 150 people to me I'm like
I'm for the next hour and a half I'm
might as well be Drake because
[__] showed out you know what
I'm saying like that's how I'll be
seeing this [__] so it's like I love
doing this [__] bro like touring is
probably my favorite part of this whole
[__] bro because like that's what that's
songs are just ideas until you see them
in real life bro
if I mean like songs are just like when
you can see and touch the people and
like really be like oh you [__] with
that or like you the first you play a
song in the first three seconds someone
look like the Dude Looks at this girl
they're like oh you're like oh yeah
that's what we do this [__] for you feel
me like that's it you feel me yeah you
feel me all right yes that's the [__] I
want to hear man you just love it to
love it and plus the hell yeah I mean
you're just putting out music right
you're putting out music
yeah [__] pops off
dude look forward don't worry Mario's
gonna be covered yeah yeah at the end of
the day okay yeah no wow so you go on
tour with Macklemore hell yeah first
show you obviously walk out to a bigger
crowd than 150. hell yeah it was like it
was like the Roseland Theater so I think
and even for him he was doing the small
tour but for me it was like because for
him he had just come off like the Can't
Hold Us run and type [__] so he was
doing Arenas so he did the small tour
just to be safe so it was only like 2
000 people but to me the 2 000 [__]
people bro like I was just playing 100
people at a college in like Bellingham
so I'm like what the hell you know what
I'm saying but
yeah we did two sold out nice in
Portland and like I drove my [__]
weak ass little Chevy Cavalier up there
bro and like yeah like the door was like
barely opening like we were damn near
like is this gonna get to Portland type
stuff like and just to get off that and
then get into a tour bus like I have a
photo of it parked in next to the tour
bus it was so hard bro like yeah bro
those are the moments I think about all
the time like I think the show the shows
were cool like I think
with the Macklemore fans sometimes
you're you're the thing in the way of
Macklemore they're like I'm here for I'm
here for the hits baby like like what is
this what is this skater rap [__] you
trying to throw at me right now you know
what I'm saying but like no it's they
are also like some of the shows were
amazing like we did terminal five in New
York and like
to have like 2 000 followers playing
Terminal 5 in New York when you're not
from there at all to like it's not
normal at all you feel me like that [__]
so like yeah he gave me a super big
boost in the beginning bro of like
mad love and [__] like he got me like a
billboard article
wow and [__] he was trying to sign me
and [__] so like it was kind of like in
part of that but like it was at the same
time like bro is like a good ass person
and like helps help really help me out
in the beginning
so like but yeah after that though like
I said like I found out like right when
I get home I find out you're cut at the
end of the school year like but you also
get paid through the summer so it's like
I'm gonna get paid to not go to work
like oh [__] I have time to rap for real
like let's go crazy so you start taking
this serious that's when I that's when I
started taking it serious as a business
because I was taking it serious but as
an art yeah it was like oh [__] like
this pays enough to like get by but like
if I want to make it real like it's time
to turn the [__] up so I linked up with
the homie Dylan Fout and we put out like
probably like 100 like it's not 100 like
50 music videos in the beginning bro it
was crazy bro like we did a song for
like we did a video for every song we
did a movie for the album we did it at a
movie sold at a movie theater in Seattle
for it oh [__] bro like 2018 was when I
really like yeah I mean people I think
you good is probably like it's not my
biggest album by any means but that's
where we see like the most tattoos
that's the most requested vinyl that's
what like
people like love for me you know crazy
and it was 2018 that was when I was like
the hungriest too that so it's it's
interesting to think about you know what
I'm saying because like the other music
is way bigger but that's the song like
people show up to the shows and like
want to hear that [__] most meaningful
yeah you know what I'm saying like
that's what had the most impact it's
that God Loves Ugly album oh yeah yeah
you know what's funny
yeah no you know it's so funny is I
didn't I bro I didn't grow up on bro
like that at all so like I I texted my
manager one time and I was like what
about an album called like God Loves
Ugly he goes first he goes like are you
being dead [__] serious
it was like dude do the [__] do the
Googles bro you're [__] up bro yeah
nah for real though yeah and that's but
that is the most impactful [__] yeah
artists hit those stretches like two
three four times in their career when
you look at them though like yeah and
that's what and that's why I think it's
beautiful right now it's like I feel the
same way I did back then of like almost
on some like like oh [__] I am a rapper
and like if but at the same time like if
I want to sustain this [__] and actually
have a legacy it's time to go [__]
crazy you know what I'm saying there's
so many parallels bro I'm sorry I'm just
in my head I'm just cheering marks
checking they're checking Mark like yo I
used to work in a factory I did boxed
wine I hated it I mean old Mexican
ladies I didn't speak Spanish here like
that was me bro because they thought
they wouldn't I thought I was Mexican
I just didn't speak Spanish and I worked
at McDonald's too all the old Mexican
[__] with me because I didn't speak
Spanish right 2018 is where I was like
I'm Gonna Do videos for real so what do
you say I'm like I'm for real weird
because that was also hungry because
that's when people started tagging this
back then too yeah 2018 yeah but that's
when I started doing YouTube like that's
when I really started doing YouTube was
2018. those are the people still rocking
bro come on that's the best [__] when
you see somebody wear a shirt they show
something like I put that out Five Years
bro I'm telling you bro like I'm
watching kids grow up
like I'm watching like literally like
ideas like I had a kid like yeah real
life kids are on the bro like
[__] are like oh yeah I used to
listen to you all through high school
and I'm like bro you have a beard that's
what I said
like what the if you look older than me
what the [__] like yo this [__] blows my
mind bro it's a blessing though like
that's how you know you're giving people
the real [__] though because like I said
that [__] all the time bro like
I only have like what like 600 000
monthly listeners on Spotify which is a
good number bro but like there's kids
with like a million two million who
can't tour the way we do hell no you
have a core family it's like actual real
like and like bro like we
we don't put any money into the promo
right now we're independent we're just
putting money into the content and just
letting it organ maybe I'll boost a
couple Instagram posts but like I this
is all organic bro and it's like that's
the numbers go longer when you really
see what that kind of [__] is coming
from there's like we might get a
playlist but then we get like 2 000
plays from that playlist all the rest of
the plays are just organic from real
people you know what I'm saying and
that's what that's why I just that's
another Mantra but if you just be
yourself and you give people the real
[__] you have you have that's what gives
you longevity you said it perfect though
there's people with quadruple you're
falling they can't sell a [__] 100
show 100 because they're not real
they're not real they're just a facade
of like yo listen to my [__] but in
person I couldn't give a [__] about it
most people I don't say most people a
lot of music just be sounding like
generated like you put like rap song
Love
hip-hop dark piano cranked it generator
that's what the [__] be sounding like
bro and I don't mean to sound like a
hitter because I don't think I'm like
the best in the [__] world but at the
same time it's just like I don't know
like that's just not sustainable bro no
it's no longevity in that you're not
giving anything to the world I feel like
bro like Get Out The Way
facility yeah yeah yeah but it yeah I
don't I don't mean it's not like I hate
it though because no no you saw posi
Vibes over here you're saying what you
need to say because I get it because
sometimes I'm like I don't mean to sound
like I'm being a dick yeah sometimes
like that's how I exactly how I feel no
in real life a lot of music because I
really give a [__] about this [__] and
it's just like I can tell a lot of
people don't give a [__] about this [__]
so it's hard to not be like [__] get out
the way you know what I'm saying I'm
sure so yeah
way left right yeah real quick before I
even forget you grew up basically an
only child because your sister's seven
years older and you're not being a [__]
out of you hell no it's a three to
ten-year-old punching the
three-year-olds [__] no she's like a 4.0
student like like good ass kid and I was
like the kid who stopped playing sports
and just like running off being a skater
[__] up like not going to school type
[__] yeah I feel you yeah it was one it
was one of them things so but it was
cool though because I always say like I
would love to have a daughter first and
then wait a couple years because having
an older sister was a blessing bro like
she's like saved me from not being a
[__] like dweeb for real like you
know what I'm saying like I would do
some she'd be like that's corny bro you
one of them guys who does that [__]
that's corny and you're like you're like
sticks with you though oh I know not to
be that now you know what I'm saying
like and that's real life it's not like
she was never no hater on me like if
whatever I wanted to do she was
supportive but if I did say it or did
some corny [__] that like she didn't
[__] with in guys she'd be like you lame
like that ain't it and it kind of that's
why like I would love to have a daughter
who like would tell my son like don't be
no [__] weirdo don't be no lame don't
be no you know what I'm saying like yeah
so we did Rocco that's weird if you like
it it's cool but I don't like it
my little brother is 15 years younger
than me so like that's really your
little bro yeah that's how I taught him
like yo that's just
man that's lame damn so exactly what she
did I did it I get it it's like now I
realize I want you to be the coolest
[__] ever but I'm not gonna
Force you exactly that's how it is yeah
exactly and like I said we got cool ass
parents too who are like yeah yeah she's
an art student too like yeah 4.0 and an
art student yeah she went yeah she went
to like art school yeah she went to she
got an art degree from a regular
University but yeah what did she do uh
now I she doesn't do anything in art now
but she she's dead on the side but like
I I I don't know exactly what she does
she does like data input no she like
runs her office I don't know exactly
what she does isn't it crazy when you're
like I don't know I know where she works
and I'm not gonna say it but like yeah
it's one of this one it's like an air
forwarding type thing like you know
where like she runs shipping stuff I
know that all right yeah yeah I feel you
my older sister like I know she works
with terpenes in a factory
it's like terpenes for perfumes and she
runs the warehouse
she's gonna be pissed if she sees this
okay I've asked her like four or five
times what do you be doing for real like
I don't know I know she works hard
though I'm not trying to say that I'm
not sure she must be super stoked the
little ass brother yeah bro that's
awesome and she and she put me on to a
lot of music too in the beginning like
you know I'm saying she was the one who
like taught me what like Green Day and
like Fallout Boy and Blink 182 was and
[__] you know what I'm saying but the
end of my dad is the one who put me on
to like yeah like M and the Fugees and
[__] Public Enemy and [__] you know
what I'm saying I had a good mix I had a
good mix yeah my dad is super into like
everything too like it would it was
mostly other [__] that was mostly like
The Clash nice my mom too yeah he loves
it he loves The Clash and like the sex
pistols and like what the [__] is
happening
everything you just named
yeah no real life bro like yeah but I
once you realize I love rappers when
he's like okay let me let me show you
the rap albums then and it was it was
like The Eminem Show
and like the miseducation the score by
the fujis I want them to you know I'm
saying Public Enemy [__] yeah and then
yeah now he's it's time bro my parents
are real music heads listen to Eminem as
a kid don't you like
oh [__] no my mom didn't want me to
listen to it bro so he would only play
on the way to sportship oh
no I swear to God but that's what was
hard about it though I remember
listening to him and being scared bro
it's why listen to like Kim like as a as
a kid you killed you you yeah you killed
your wife you hate your mom catch up on
a shirt why that's blood I was a kid
like no yeah being a little kid and
hearing Stan for the first time you're
like oh my God bro like I'm telling you
like that's yeah but that's what like
man I miss that [__] me up he's a video
[__] man no wait she's did the drug
so how'd they find the tape
yeah
how'd they find this tape
any nailed it to Eminem at the end the
police were like well let's at least
military
it was for him it was for Mr Slim we got
to do it bro
it's hella funny
how do you send it no for real man I was
just I was just talking the other day
bro like Eminem is like literally my
[__] goat but at the same time like
it's just like like
my homie walked in on me watching Eight
Mile and he goes oh that's how you
feeling and I was like I was like
embarrassed I was like bro Eminem is the
goal but why am I kind of embarrassed
watching Eight Mile right
but I've watched get Richard I turned
seven thousand times I would go Rich get
rich eight miles real Eminem though
everything eight mile is hard though
like he's only watched it why would you
be embarrassed to watch eight miles I
don't know maybe it's I think it's a
rapper thing of like like is it like is
it like you stoking yourself up like
football player watching Rudy yeah
that's what I'm saying that's kind of
that's what I mean
it feels like being a rapper like oh
you're getting amps watching eight miles
like a [__] nerd
like a [__] nerd exactly for real bro
no That's a classic though but so you
went back to all his early mixtapes all
the Slim Shady oh for sure hell yeah
hell yeah especially I mean I still
listen I listen to that [__] more now
than I used than I even did as a kid bro
like that [__] is so hard bro and a lot
of people rap like Eminem but they don't
sound like Eminem so that he doesn't get
the credit
like what do you mean like jid is hella
Eminem influence yeah [__]
don't put things like that together I I
guess I guess so I think that way that's
what I'm saying I think that way about
Wayne too A lot of people rap like Lil
Wayne but they don't sound like Lil
Wayne so he doesn't get the credit
kind of does okay jid sounds to me like
Lil Wayne and Eminem were like it's like
I'm trying to like and like some
Southern verses and like yeah yeah you
know what I'm saying like Okay but
Eminem it's different it's just
different but it's like you're talking
about the Cadence I guess yeah I just
mean that the way sometimes people will
write the way sometimes people will
attack uh like a flow or their voice the
way they say some [__] like I don't know
Eminem early Eminem is still like I feel
like you can still feel that in like
rapping ass rappers right now feel me in
rapping ass rappers yeah because there's
there's people who rap and there's
people who like rap for real I mean as
far as we're like one big long stretched
out thought just kind of like that like
yeah like never ending flow like this
[__] just keeps going and going and
going and going like yeah
that's how I felt about that's how I
feel about Lil Wayne too like I'd be
rapping like Lil Wayne too and I feel
like no one makes the connection because
like but like sometimes I'll follow the
same
like flow that's crazy I'd be rapping
like Lil Wayne no one says it like that
I just mean like I'm trying to like I
just mean like I'm like I'll follow
Cadence is the same way like you know
what I'm saying or like he'll like how
like he'll use the same rhyme scheme for
a whole verse and just like attack the
same thing over and that's what I be
feeling like I be trying to do you know
what I'm saying like so I'll be and I
see in other people's work too like M
and like Wayne have to like have so much
influence there's a lot of foundation
it's a lot of foundation for people [__]
that they don't get credit for in a way
I've never heard anyone say that before
no realize it does make sense now that
you think about it because you you'd
make using music and you do music so
yeah I'm on the outside looking in like
Oh you mean the building blocks the
building base of how am I gonna attack
like I get I get what you're saying now
like it's like skeleton of a video like
what am I thinking I'm trying to think
of how you guys are um officially bro oh
yeah so what's your process now like how
how do you write songs man I just
I usually just link up with producers
and like right now I'm super on doing
collab albums with producers because
that's just like my to Jake one right
now yeah I just put out the album with
Jake one and I got another one coming
with Nema who's done like all of my
music from the beginning well for
everyone saying like how can they find
that that uh yes right now it's called
it's called wolves and White T's Travis
Thompson and Jake one you can go find it
on anywhere like Spotify Apple music
actively put down old [__] right now
yeah yeah we're still putting out videos
like I just dropped some [__] yesterday
for it you know what I'm saying like
yeah bro like it's it's a great it's a
crazy moment for Seattle too Jake one is
a legend from the city you know what I'm
saying he's produced for everybody and
then some who I'm saying from like 50
nifty fruit at the Philly freeway you
know I'm saying freeway
[__] Rick Ross like Drake everybody
bro like
the John Cena intro is a jake one you
know what I'm saying like John Cena
legendary yeah so it's like and I grew
up on Jake one music you feel me so like
it's a moment for the city too so like
yeah please go tapping with the album
but right now I'm just working on collab
albums with producers like I got one
with Nema who's done a lot of my OG
music and like it's like probably my
favorite one I have right now because it
sounds like me bro it's like one of them
things where like
when I wrap over a jake One Beat I'm
kind of he's he's flipping I'm right I'm
like in his world but when I put out
this Nema album it's like this is me you
know I'm saying this is like us like
giving something new to music type [__]
you know what I'm saying but then I got
one with Chris P he's a guy from cat
from Tacoma from a group called I'll
fight you and yeah yeah no they're hard
bro and then yeah and then me and logic
are working on tape you know what I'm
saying he's producing some [__] for me
you know what I'm saying so we got a lot
we're about to go on a run man so it
feels real [__] good but that's the
process now though is just like either
getting up with people making [__] on
scratch because like I I like rapping is
my job now so I can just cook in the
studio now for a while I had to like go
home with Beats and really sit with them
and [__] but now and I still will but
like for the most part now I can just
cook up on the spot and just spit you
know what I mean and or they just
sending me because like I can't cook up
a lot I'm a [__] busy bro he's a dad
you touring the world and [__] yeah but
like
yeah for them it's real simple [__]
right now yeah I love that idea of just
doing like collab albums or producers so
you get like certain sounds bro it makes
a sound the most cohesive like and also
like producers don't get enough love in
this [__] bro so it's like it's it's
cool for people to root for both of us
you know what I'm saying it's like I
don't know yeah you're really showing
love instead of taking like 15 beats per
month and sprinkling them over like four
different projects like no this is our
sound right here people know what
they're getting you feel me yeah it's
like yeah it's like in it super it like
strengthens come live in this world you
know what I'm saying because that's
that's my favorite kind of music and it
feels like I can escape you know I'm
saying I can listen to this album and
really like damn I mean like in this
[__] like Universe you know
what I'm saying and that's what we and
like when you lock in with a producer
like that's what it is bro like you
really are like creating a a thing you
feel me as opposed to like having like
10 producers on an album with like 15
songs like like I don't know it's harder
to like
find a
thought or like convey a thought you
know what I'm saying yeah dance it's so
hard for me I'm trying I'm following you
but it's the Slim Shady it's Dr Dre's
saying this is my take on Eminem I'm
trying to put my nah for real bro yeah
yeah so like the whole album even though
they're different songs or different
words different scenarios you're trying
to say like the overall theme kind of
stays yes it's just it's yeah it's
easier to like yeah just create a one
big idea if it's just you and one
producer gotcha and it's like yeah
people want to root for producers bro
people want to know who made these beats
people want to know who's like I don't
know producers are getting more shy now
than ever and it's like a good thing
you for me yeah and if I can contribute
to that it's lit
you feel me yeah um question we ask a
lot of people randomly off topic and not
even about music yeah 16 year old you
walks in hella pissed are you gonna beat
the [__] out of him or he's gonna beat
the shadow 16 year old me yeah uh he's
probably beating my ass right now yeah I
think so bro I'm super soft now bro and
I was super soft in don't get me wrong
I've always been hella soft I ain't
never claiming to be nothing bro but
like 16 year old me was wild bro 16 year
old me might like hit the homie cup and
lean because it's like
because it's cool and 16 year old me
might [__] like was stealing from
parties and [__] getting like jumped in
Des Moines Washington for like stealing
from someone's ex Xbox or their
Grandma's [__] medication or
something oh we were wild
like we were like so 16 year old me was
actually I'd be rapping about like 16
year old me damn near here bro because I
was I was actually like now bro I wake
up bro like I'll slow cook some ribs for
like four hours watch a podcast like do
some yoga bro you feel me like smoke
like I'm I'm a I'm a big old softy I
would I've always been a big osaki but I
was definitely doing harder [__] back
then
no I'm definitely whipping his ass he
was a [__] he was a [__] dead too I'm
a [__] too but this is like no I got
him I'm older now and I have like adult
aggression like I've had to like I've
had to like pay money the IRS you know
what I'm saying so adult aggression I
like that we used to call old man
straight but you're not old yeah I'm not
old at all but like I've had to like
deal with bills and like you know what
I'm saying real life so six year old me
[__] him bro
go to class get your stupid ass bro go
to school go to school you [__] loser
bro he like what you always say crazy
because at the time you're like no
schooling for [__] and now I'm like
yo what was I do bro I was folding bro
it's school was not hard bro I think
about it all the time bro it's so much
it's so bad because it's like you want
to tell the kids like I feel you but as
I look back and I'm like bro what was I
doing for I had no stressors what was I
so like oh my God bro yeah I don't want
to be here but this ain't for me you
can't just sit there yeah
you can't just show up get a c and like
walk for your mom to watch
bro yeah no real life no I watch her I
watched her I graduated with a 1.9 oh
damn yeah you squeaked yeah bro I bet
because I because they wanted me to put
like
they I came back from an alternative
school and they were like you got to
take all six classes and I was like I
only need three credits bro I'm only
going to three of these classes and
they're like no you got to stay you
can't just let you go home and I was
like well how good of a grade do I need
in these three classes I'll just take
F's on the other ones like I'm not going
to college it's cooked I'm not going
like I just need to walk so my mom can
like get a photo because I'm not so I'm
not a loser wow yeah because I already
knew I was trying to be a rapper like I
knew like I was like it's like I'm not
cut out to work for nobody like I'm lazy
unless I really love it bro you know
what I'm saying like unless it's like
I'm passionate about it it's hard to
keep me like locked in so it's like I
knew even in high school I was like I
just need to walk for my mom and so she
can get the flick and we can go to like
Olive Garden and
keep it pushing man got some [__]
raspberry lemonade yeah no I was in I
was in my counselor office like please
just let me walk bro like I'll go to
summer school whatever I don't give a
[__] bro just let me walk bro
[Laughter]
I've said this in the story time before
like my mom is gonna stab me if I don't
walk I gotta walk I'll go to summer
school I'll do it I had summer school
Saturday school one a night school and
after school God damn the last three
months my mom never knew I didn't tell
her God she would have stabbed so what
you're saying like I can't be it's like
a mix of our lives
right this was like oh he's he's feeling
that aggression he's like I can't do I
already knew no I haven't been there yet
Bro [__] 16 year old it is funny
wow
I love hearing stories like this we
always have to ask guests like yeah
Joe's sister used to beat this [__] we
asked DJ Drama so your sister used to
beat the [__] out here or something just
to throw his ass off he's like you know
no one's ever asked him what'd he say
nah man she's like a little six seven
years older than me so you know it's
different but like hell no my homies
beat the [__] out of me bro I was like
yeah bro I was the softy of like the I
was like the one being like no like so
why you stealing bro like I don't want
him bro I don't want to steal right now
I was still either bro like I I
definitely stole but I hated it bro like
I was like I remember like you're
walking out of a store and your homie
just runs past you and it's like bro now
we're running bro now we're running now
[__] and like we get caught and now now
they see me tearing up and now you're
the bad kid the whole bus ride home
they're like this little [__]
was crying he's a [__] bro yeah no I
hated that [__] I knew I was like yeah
for real yo
I'm a petty crime boy though I'm the
crime life was not for me even I I I I
remember I bought like an ounce of weed
and then my homie got robbed and I was
like oh yeah he's way tougher than me
it's over I'm done
it's done I'm not smiling I'm not
selling all these
they put a gun on my bro it's over bro
oh no I'm not I'm too soft for that yeah
I'm not getting the gun pull down there
bro it's over bro we had a gun pull down
like my group on there had a gun pulled
on me so like no it's good I'm not
selling no [__] weed bro that was
back in medical days too though that was
like back in yeah
I mean yes it's definitely kind of wild
bro it's super yeah yeah it's definitely
kind of wild bro it's one of them places
where I don't it's like super random
and and there's certain neighborhoods
where like you kind of like you find it
yourself or
who where you're from or who your family
is or where you grew up can kind of like
lead you into some crazy [__] but for
the most part it's not that bad bro it
sounds like everywhere yeah it's like
I'm not yeah I'm not here to like
glorify nothing and or like have to
speak for nothing but at the same time
like yeah Seattle and Tacoma are active
though but like I'm not the guy who's
who's here to like break the streets
down you know what I'm saying you feel
me oh there's game makers there no but
you know in Burien like I know if you
come to like where I'm from like you'll
see the tags you'll see the you'll see
like kids like who are definitely active
West Coast [__] yeah like I'm saying
like all you remember I pulled up on the
homies house I'm like I'm getting banged
on outside by some random like 18 year
olds and I'm like oh damn this is crazy
hey guys
yeah bro like ask your big homie like I
promise like I'm trying to [__] game
reverse you know what I'm saying like
bro like I'm chilling but you know what
I'm saying like yeah so there's
definitely that [__] but isn't it crazy
for the most part it's only if you like
the hair
uh yeah yeah bro if I have a beat yeah
no for sure you're still getting hit up
people with the hair I always think it's
like I look at skater kid leave me alone
nah for showing bro I've had my fingers
asked because I have Boulevard boys
tatted on my hands and [__]
have been like what's Boulevard boys
mean and it's like bro I'm a rapper bro
it's just my business bro I'm from
Seattle bro like no I'm not even yeah
but I don't want any problems
no but it's random it's random [__] like
and also like yeah people like you think
people think you're native people think
I'm Mexican yeah so sometimes if I'm in
a neighborhood it's like what are you
doing you know what I'm saying what
you're doing but it's never enough it's
never nothing bro like it's never I'm
not saying it's never crazy see how
especially Mike it's not crazy bro I'm
not here to glorify or say anything
anything's crazy for me because for the
most part bro like I said I'm slow
cooking some ribs bro I'm skating at the
skate park like I'm gonna chill ass like
I'm out the way can you can you actively
hit balls oh yeah I'm better at bowls
than than I am like flat ground because
I grew up in a skate park for real with
transition Bulls are so scary for me bro
I can like go I can like air a spine bro
damn I'm telling you as a 250 pound man
I will like I will oh [__] I will like
yeah hit some nose grabs out of a bowl
for you bro yeah and I bro I had the
nose grab show I'm yeah and I'm a
transition boy fish out what the [__]
yeah yo come on man yeah man
I went to the skate park and tried to
hit the ball once went up
landed on my back board hit me never
again yeah that should have changed your
life though it did it changed my life as
I went up saw my feet went I'm falling
you know done you know it's so funny
though it's like I was I was a kid
learning the bowls hella quickly and not
really learning like I learned how to
like go in and out of bowls and [__]
before I was like kid clipping so like
yeah I was a skatepark kid you know what
I'm saying so like
I remember like one day though like
there's the biggest bowl it's probably
like six or seven foot drop you know
what I'm saying so like I was like 12
just ollieing into it just trying to all
eat it flat and I was just breaking
myself off like hitting my head like
breaking my [__] and then that day
though was like the day the homies were
like you trying to go to Burger King and
it was like I was like inducted to the
[__] skate park you know what I'm
saying yeah this one [__] hurt
himself like 30 times yeah this kid
don't give a [__] man hit this blunt
your other group of friends especially
bro yeah that was yeah man like I'm
definitely a skateboarder damn near
before a rapper if that makes sense
yeah like that's what we actually like
oh yeah I spent more time skateboarding
than rapping but I'm not hell of filthy
or nothing but like yeah
I love it now though I'm definitely
wrapping more but I'm washed not skating
now it's ass
I guess like I said I can still air
spines and [__] I can still do impress
especially for my size I go to the skate
park people are like oh you actually
skate I'm like you're right that's what
I'm saying damn right you can hit the
spot I can try flip consistently
you used to skate for real yeah bro I'm
real skater bro you can go to YouTube
and look up Travis Thompson like skate
with sk84 Burien you can look up like
skate videos of me like yeah bro me and
the homies when I'm like a little kid
with like VX cameras and [__] that's
sick all my homies were the skater kids
and one from Merced you're it's either
gangbanger kids or or like the few white
kids that skate and I hung out with a
few white kids at skate because hell
yeah but they're real like let's go to
the loading dock like I'll watch you
I'll smoke bowls out of this can with
this guy yeah while you do the loading
I'm not breaking my legs for sure but
there's everyone's age where that
happened too even if you really skated
there's a I remember when I think it was
when I turned 16 it was like oh yeah I'm
not gonna go pro or no it's probably
like I was like 15. I was like I'm not
gonna go pro I'm I'm let me hit this
blunt let me someone let me let me hit
the tall boy I'm here to watch my
friends who really skate yeah he get 360
flip and grab that [__]
he's like kick flipping downstairs sets
and [__] I'm just here to hit some a
six-pack and like post it on my Snapchat
story no stall on the curb real quick
you're too skinny and athletic I'm like
you guys are so much better than
everyone you see the fully skate parking
start stacking trash cans oh for sure we
were doing that oh that shit's the floor
I love that [__] was fun skate park [__]
is where like I'm at I think about all
the time if I never became a skate park
kid I probably wouldn't be a rapper
because like because like skate park
[__] is what like introduced me to
obviously like there's like things in my
life I rap about that are just like
family and [__] but like at the same
time like the skate park is what opened
me to the world before that I was just a
kid who's playing at the house and going
to like sporting [__] but then like I
got a [__] skateboard and a bus pass
and it was just the city it's over like
I'm 12 years old out till like 4 a.m
skating with the homies and [__] like we
were whiling bro like but that's what it
was that's been skating in Seattle
introduced you to life too like that's
what I'm saying bro like I was just I
was on the bus getting into crazy
situations all throughout Washington
damn near like in the crazy thing about
the age you're doing wild [__] and then
you think about like a cousin or
something like you're 12. I beat the
[__] out of you if you're doing some
[__] on the bus at 3am bro no real life
bro I think all the time too I'm like
who was passing me blunts when I was 12
bro like all the time that's not cool
bro that's not [__] cool you know
what I'm saying like you don't get no
points for passing no way to a kid bro
but he was 13 I was 12. no it was like
16 17 year olds who [__] know better
bro 18 19 year olds who are like crazy
handed me like like 40s and [__] when
I'm like 12 and I'm like bro I would
have never done that well obedience yeah
bro I'm like oh yeah like you see it
like bro yeah that was me though the
homies were like when I was a little kid
the homies would bring me to parties and
[__] when I was like 12 13 bro oh see I
was like 14 is when that started for me
that's why when mid 90s came out I was
like bro what the [__] bro this is my
[__] life
this is my [__] life this is my
[__] life what the [__] man I wanted
to make this movie
man yeah
[__] no all I said was that Jonah Hill
something's in trouble and I went uh he
was just texting his girl some kind of
lame [__] but at the same time like it
was from years ago so she's kind of
he was texting some lame [__] takes her
some some like kind of some controlling
[__] as a dude oh he's being a weirdo
yeah I think so a little bit I wouldn't
have said no taxes you don't have a
seven-year-old sister but I saw people
with some people would say yeah some
people would say he was set in
boundaries but I think it's a little
extra but at the same time super bad is
[__] classic
so it ain't into my [__] business
really I'm just here making content
brother the liquor store is right down
the street
the actual one my homie every time
you're dead the [__] ass yeah it's right
down the street after I'm going yes it's
so funny to see it like I gotta get in
close to these warlocks
oh I'm buying some I'm buying a bottle
from there yeah
oh my God
yo where the [__] do you live well I
feel like we've been chilling for eight
years and [__] where are you where do
you live right now I live in Seattle you
still live in Seattle yeah I'm back and
forth to L.A a lot yeah hit me up
I feel like I'm just chilling back in in
the garage hanging out come on brother
that's my vibe that's what I want that's
what I want my whole vibe to be bro as a
rapper bro like you can invite me to
your bummy ass garage with like a pool
table and there's like nowhere to sit
for real and I would that like and I
would smoke with you and we would like
about that's my vibe if you [__] with
that listen to my [__] yeah if you
subscribe this guy's games apart uh
garage we used to chill out oh hell yeah
bro nowhere to sit pool
tables there's a pile of dirty clothes
over there if you want to go sit on that
you know what I'm saying like yeah and
we playing 2K right now so yeah yeah
that's the exact Vibe yeah that's my
whole vibe as a rapper bro yeah
um oh yeah oh oh we're chilling I I mean
I don't even know if I got something I
wanted to bust out I don't know if I
want to do it yet I mean we could do it
and then just keep continuing which
would be kind of awesome what is it but
you smoke you kind of scaring me
you rightfully should be slightly scared
okay I get it I understand but you gotta
go freestyle bootleg cab after this
how what time like how how long uh not
for like another two hours I think so
we're chilling but yeah yeah he's good I
gotta go freestyle
okay
um
let's just do it yeah so for the first
time ever for the first time ever
what is this
what in the [__] is this
I gotta have zip grind it up in this
[__]
what I'm gonna burn it and we're just
gonna and you don't be playing you
probably like that's probably some good
weed in there it's oh it's all fire I
even left some [__] person like I'll
go to weed events and they're just
blowing oh my gosh I grinded it right
out of my job and look at that I just
left whole nugs just to say [__] it oh
my God you're sick you're a sick [__]
Jesus Christ what type of [__] is you on
bro I don't know we had this it was like
insane it's kind of awesome right what
the [__]
oh my God yes I thought you were gonna
spray that [__] in my face that's what
she said
yeah that was a crazy pause
hey yo my bad that was insane
you're like [__] record scratch
insane run that back that was insane but
yeah you ready yeah I haven't tried it
really so
you're crazy all right here we go this
is it
you ever wonder like do I smoke too much
weed and then and then this [__] happens
around you and you're like oh yeah for
sure that's me yeah I smoke a lot there
we go
[__] real one dude
oh
[Music]
[__]
just like oh my God house fire in here
oh maybe I'm doing it too hard the
water's coming out
this is insane
holy [__]
[Music]
yeah this guy's really got the [__]
weed blicky
crazy what the [__] coming to push trees
very soon look at the lights
oh oh [__] oh we're overdoing it guys
spillage did you make that no no no
we're about to make it for my my company
holy [__]
that's hard
oh there's so much weed left hold up let
me re-light this [__] how much you put
in there let me have zip holy [__]
that [__] looks crazy you hear it
that's why she is sick I need these when
I'm walking in this is my WWF [__]
intro right here damn it's my WWE I've
been walking with two all right
flamethrower [__] Rambo
well yeah so I know you're small so I
was like you know what let's do this
yeah box this [__] out man
why not and then then I'll ask you some
more questions you want the joint it's
hitting the joint and we you damn right
[Music]
lucky I'm pulling up on bootleg Kev his
ass be smoking oh he does yeah I think
so he'd be doing the shrinking too
you do shrimps hell yeah [__] yeah you
do acid never tried it still why not uh
I'll tell you right now
oh that that [__] that's just that's
just on fire let's just wait
that shit's smoking like crazy okay here
we go
so yeah my aunt used to do acid all the
time and I remember her friends used to
ask all the time she's like 12 years
older than me so I was like nine we
chilled at her friend's house all the
time she was cool yeah then one day we
go over and she is insane she says the
craziest [__]
and she's like schizophrenic and then my
aunt explains to me that she got a
badass a tab and
when nuts yeah still it's been 25 years
she's for sure like that and I hear you
so it scared me to death you know you
know what went wrong in that story what
you said she did ask it all the time
that was the bad part that's the bad
part bro if you ask it is something you
should do all the time no yeah bro you
do ask it a few times a year I feel like
bro man then maybe that's some [__]
[__] but like that real [__] really
rewires your brain a little bit so like
yeah mushrooms though yeah I'll be doing
too many shrooms now because it's just
it's too easy everyone's giving me
[__] shrimp chocolates everywhere I
go eat like gummies they taste good yeah
like oh my God yeah you feel me some of
them are fake though I definitely had
one that was not mushrooms really I
don't know what it was but I felt like
sick and like I don't know like I was
like vibrating or something it was weird
bro I don't know if it was like some
cheap Molly or something like gummy no
it's chocolate
I definitely had a fake one so I'd be
kind of weird you know I'd be worried
about the Chinese chocolates too just no
I like the straight up strings because
people be like grossed out by that [__]
but like nah I can just pop them shits
like it's nothing oh do you oh it takes
me forever to break those [__] down
for real it's like I'm chewing for 30
minutes but we got the tech Fruit
Roll-Up
roll it in a fruit roll-up
bite it It Coats it and you just eat a
fruit roll-up there is no mushroom yeah
it works we've been doing the peanut
butter banana sandwiches with the
shrooms
is it you can't even tell because
there's so much [__] like other [__]
that there's bread peanut butter and
bananas so like them shrooms are gone
you can eat all eighth and not even tell
you put mushrooms in there oh [__]
that's true that's true actually yeah
but damn you guys go hard if you're
making a full sandwich like that oh no
I'm not doing a full age my homies be
doing full Ace and [__] that [__] scares
me bro like I'd be doing like little two
grammers wait a little bit do a little
two grand I don't know something bro
like I'll do an eighth over like the
course of a few hours oh okay but like I
don't know I some my homies be gone my
homies be out of here you know what I'm
saying like doing like tabs of acid and
[__] like I don't get that [__] like I
don't I like to do it seldomly and like
shake it as like a little I don't know
I'd be corny about it I'd be like really
like exploring myself on that ship hey
man there's a lot of people that they
like you have to send intentions before
you go and do a trip and [__] like yeah
I don't know about if I'm doing that but
like I'll see I like to [__] I like to
[__] get a good cry off on some acid
sometimes oh [__] you feel me like I
tried it really like I did some acid one
time we were camping and then like we
saw a bear going to the store and then
my girl was like you know you were like
meant to see that bear
and I was like damn don't say that to me
right now no I'm crying off the acid but
I just feel good to cry
yeah something like a real like a bear
crossed the road we were like camping is
that normal wait and like I thought you
said a bear go into a store I was going
to a store Oh I thought you said well I
saw a bear go into a store I was like oh
no no for sure it was close to the story
different bro sorry I'm like yeah
hella funny but nah I was going to the
store and I saw a bear and like I cried
because I was meant to see that [__]
bear dude that was everything in my life
had led me to see that bear
well Marty started dabbling this room's
heavy too but I take like a big dose and
go nuts in the dark and that's just
crazy what the [__] sit in the dark no
there's no noise because everything you
think you see yeah you as a hard body
it's wild [__] I don't do that how much
are you eating
eating more than anything you're eating
a quarter every time no no when I want
to do that [__]
but you just don't like we might not eat
an eighth and like I've never an hour or
two I've never really try I I mean I
haven't done that in a couple years on
the show okay on the show last time we
took like two two grams ish a little
more oh it's nice
these ones were [__] not I mean no
two grams of some good some good shrooms
we'll do it too it was so hard to tell
you to hold the conversation
so I was doing this was there more was
it more head [__] or visual [__] head
yeah I was in my own head like I've been
talking
for sure anything
the names of shrooms be so crazy though
oh yeah if you want some penis in your
butt yeah
you want some dookie say it's so regular
like they're not saying something yeah
you want penis envy brother that's crazy
you said you just call them peas
it should be normalized I like that I
like that people [__] say oh these
are the penis enemies and the golden
cats like
and that's what everybody likes those
ones though yeah those are the ones that
hung you up but in Washington man
everyone's been doing that [__] forever
oh dude you guys are the [__] culture
of this yeah you guys are like tripping
all day yeah [__] are tweaking
up there and like that's why like I hear
I feel I do feel you want to ask this
[__] though because like I had teachers
who definitely never came down
you know what I'm saying like I had
teachers who were like yeah you can tell
this [__] was like it's still up
there that's that's so good I'd be so
mad that's why I don't take acid now
because we do the show we do everything
could you imagine if I took acid and
then you saw my post like a week later
like hey I'm a little weird now like oh
that's so sad bro I hear you but you
could do like a half a tab and be nice
bro I heard acid so much better than
mushrooms too acid to me bro is like
it's it's like more intense but I have
more control
shrooms that's like less intense but I'm
kind of like on the ride
acid like I can be tripping the [__] out
and then take a 30 second break and be
like all right I'm just tripping and
then you know what I'm saying yeah
streams you're all in shrooms you're all
in right yeah that's it you're kind of
like you just have to lean into it if
you're scared you know what I'm saying I
said I feel like you can take yourself
out of it for a second and then hop back
in but maybe that's just me I don't know
but yeah
we'll see man maybe next time I see you
I'll be like yo I tried it but I doubt
that I got some good assets we'll do
that to you
you gotta see the trees breathing oh
I've seen them grow like
taller than I could see and that [__]
was great bro yeah I've seen somebody
ever had an outer body on any of
psychedelics maybe a little bit but like
nothing I can say like it was too
significant significant or memorable no
I fasted in the desert for three days
though fasted yeah like I did like this
right like I went to an alternative
school in high school so like like we
did like the [__] called Write a passage
where we had to go to the desert for
like three days with like just a tarp
that's real I swear to God like no I've
seen that [__] on [__] King of the
Hill I swear to God yeah right a passage
yeah I didn't know that was a real thing
no I mean I think I think a lot of it
stems from like native American
traditions but it's just like some my
teacher was like a white lady with blue
hair you know what I'm saying she's cool
though you know what I'm saying but like
yeah but uh I we fasted in the fort in
the desert for three days bro I swear to
God with like just a tarp and some rope
and like three gallons of water and like
a sleeping bag and bro like I had that I
had out of body shape doing that because
I was on the third day bro with no food
nobody to talk to because you have to
guess you have to spread out what you're
that you were dead ass Alone by yourself
for three days how old were you when you
do this like 16
year old you are you 17 maybe yeah
yeah
I had out of body no no it was like a
thing we had to write an essay to go do
it and [__] it was like because there's
a base camp you could walk back to you
oh did you [__] if you're done with
it if you're yeah if you say you were
like to be yeah yeah you could quit that
sounds like but I did that [__] on the
third day bro I was having the most
insane Visions you went through that and
they gave you a [__] 1.9
[Laughter]
yeah send him to the [__] desert yeah
let's go outside no it's cool though
because like I'll never be bored again
ever in my whole life you taught
yourself how to view I I was alone with
my brain for three [__] days three
days three nights
no food
I'm telling you bro let's see what'd you
see I was I was at my own funeral bro
like I swear to God I leaned back in my
chair because I had a camping chair on
my backpack and I just like I like it
was like an orange box in front I'm like
moving away from like it was an orange
box in front of me and I was like oh
what the [__] let me just dip my head in
and now I'm like watching my own funeral
bro swear to swear to God bro and this
is no no drugs this is just no food my
own brain for three days were you older
in the in the funeral yeah I was I mean
I was dead I mean were you an old man I
don't know I don't know how I don't know
yeah bro I don't [__] I was yeah bro it
was insane that that's the only time I
ever had out of body [__] and that was
without the drugs without the drugs I'd
just be having fun
I swear to God I feel like people will
feel that though like yeah no real [__]
like if you don't eat for three days and
you're alone with your thoughts you will
start going how long into it until that
happened probably like the third day are
you sitting by your are you saying you
can't move from that spot though no you
can walk around and [__] I was walking I
like passed out by the river one time
after second day just because I was like
just like trying to walk on a walk but I
was off no food
so I just like for two days I like
passed out dangerous it was it was a
little dangerous but yo it was Travis I
think he died at that River he's dead
yeah there he is he's [__] dead sorry
to God though hey passing out on some
good grass is nice though yo are you
talking about it often I can't do it I'm
afraid of tweakers I know for sure bro
yeah
this was deep the desert but yeah
falling asleep on some grass is cool
until you wake up with like spiders in
your [__] though never mind no you never
go to sleep on [__] it's over with
Loki I'll Turf I'll fall asleep yeah you
wet yeah you real and then you you get
up because you see a spider and then you
step on a bee yeah bro I'm telling you
bro I've had that day before bro I've
had that day like [__]
dude that little that little gun was
cool
right now I was like wait yeah we really
torched that [__] yeah that shit's hard
bro that was fun I need that for the
crib yeah just to do it when people walk
in like from out of town like what's up
yeah welcome to [__] Seattle I have
this gun of weed for you yes my vibe I
took my exact Vibe yeah I need that
people like Dr Drew when they come
through no I can't do it now
he was a nice man yeah
so uh
your projects that are coming out right
now and you're doing a tour you said
um no I don't have anything exactly
announced yet but like we yeah we're
going on the road in the fall for sure
in the fall because you said last time I
talked to you like oh I'm leaving the
country right
oh I I just got it back from Europe okay
I just got back from Europe yeah my bad
but yeah no I just I just went through
Europe with I told Watsky right there it
was fire bro it was like my first time
out there my parents came my girl came
my sister came for like like the last
three days it was fine how long were you
gone I was gone for like two weeks it
was five we had like seven shows out
there bro it was like
it was some life-changing [__] bro I had
never been to Europe before none of us
had ever been there so is there a
difference between American fans and
Europeans oh hell yeah bro like European
fans are just like so much more grateful
you know what I'm saying like I don't
mean to [__] out American fans by any
means bro they're because like some of
them a lot of them have been it's not
like they're tapped in I mean not tapped
in they're like they listen to American
Music you feel me so they a lot of them
have been on the music for like five six
years so they had never thought they'd
ever see me in their head so they're
like pulling up to the shows stoked as
[__] like they're losing their minds and
[__] like that [__] was tight but also
like the European fans would like come
up and like buy a shirt and then like
not I'd be like what up they're like
trying to walk away I'm like thank you
you're saying but in America someone
buys a shirt it's a little more like hey
bro I need my I need my picture bro I
bought a shirt you know what I'm saying
it's a little different you feel me but
at the same it's like and they don't
really bring their phones out
they're just watching you bro like it's
wild it's a little it's a little
different I try to do that as much as
possible at shows no let me see a video
and be like done yeah yeah you feel me I
was here so cool yeah for sure bro and
there was a little bit more of that but
I mean like they're a little less like
for me at least there was a little less
turnt up than American fans but at the
same time it was like more grateful I
don't know it was weird but I loved it
bro like all right you're all these all
the cities I had never been it was
amazing but I was like I went to spiky
ass buildings I'm telling you bro like
you ever heard of uh Christie ever been
to Christiania Copenhagen
what it can Copenhagen in this place
called Christianity and it's like it's
like an ungoverned town in Copenhagen by
Europe or whatever so like there's no
mayor there's no nothing it's like a
Town Council or whatever that like meets
every month and like you can't take
pictures in there but there's like bars
and like restaurants and there's like a
whole community and like a lake and like
a park and like playground for kids and
[__] but there's also like an open air
hash Market I'm telling you bro it was
the coolest place I've ever been in the
whole world bro
you can go on YouTube and people have
made Vlogs about it like on the low but
like you can't really take photos or
videos in there it's like ungoverned by
Europe
the Ubers don't even go over there you
gotta take a taxi what the [__]
I'm telling you bro and the venue was
right in it
sounds like a setup
setup I'm telling you bro it's open air
hash Market but at the same time people
are like pushing strollers around
there's like a park for kids and [__]
like this yeah bricks little [__]
square just the open air everything
Market I would imagine no there's no
hard drugs there's no fighting there's
no like it's crazy bro like there's big
signs that like have say let's say like
no violence no hard drugs no like yo
it's like no violent signs help bro
there at least yeah
I'm telling you bro it's like one of
them places where like I didn't I
couldn't even believe I was there bro
it's like a different world bro it was
crazy bro I loved it bro and that's why
that Europe [__] was like amazing
because like yeah playing shows is
always crazy but like seeing the world
is like some other [__] bro like and I
yeah bro off the wraps too like it's
crazy of course man then you're over
here doing your first video outside your
school you know yeah
I'm in Europe This is insane bro and
like we're we're [__] who like
it's it was it's never been overnight
for us you know I'm saying like like I
said we we started taking this [__]
serious at the same time it's like it's
a [__] Journey bro yes I literally
said all the time where we were half a
decade into this [__] like bro like it's
it's insane and it's still on an upward
trajectory so it's like how could you
not like go super hard and be grateful
you feel me yeah that spoken word video
you did on your channel holy [__] you're
talking about everything about your
journey and like overcoming and ramping
oh yeah oh yeah that's amazing damn oh
damn yeah yeah bro that that
that yeah I just try to be on some real
[__] like just doing your podcast give
people a [__] yeah for real bro I try
to give people a [__] yeah I didn't
even realize there was on some spoken
word [__] but damn it [__] it is yeah
but yeah bro like
yeah we're like you got to give people
the reason to root for you bro if you
there's there's no UPS if there's if
there ain't Downs bro like you feel me
like
and that's why I think the music is
is more I don't know it's the most it's
the best it's ever been bro because it's
just like giving people the real [__] on
like a higher level than it's ever been
that at least I've ever given it bro
like yeah well you know that feeling
like you said like I feel like I did in
2018. that's what I'm saying bro again
bro like I feel very like we're we're
about to go on a run and we're on a run
right now you know I'm saying like this
[__] is opportunity for me bro so I
appreciate y'all bro I appreciate you
for real bro thank you you feel me so it
feels it feels good bro we're like super
back in the swing of things and even out
here being out here in LA and [__] doing
these interviews and [__] I'm like oh
yeah this is what I do like I'm about to
go ravish oh yeah okay you feel me it
feels good bro yeah then you gotta go to
boo like this I'm so sorry I'm about to
be getting away yeah you need to wake up
I'm literally gonna tell him he's gonna
be like this [__] guy he came all
[__] around
[__] bro what happened
wait who did who did we do that to we
did that before I forget we did that to
somebody and then we found out people
people who watch both who are gonna be
like oh yeah he's cooked
um so how can everybody find you how can
everybody follow you man if you Google
Travis Thompson bro like you find me
everywhere you can follow me Travis X
Thompson so Travis is excellent there
you go t-h-o-n-p-s-o-n but yeah bro
that's everywhere like and Spotify Apple
music bro I ain't hard to find bro like
I got a goofy ass haircut and I'll be
rapping hard as [__] bro so
come tap in bro come tap in I love it
that should be the name here I got a
goofy ass hair kind of rap artist you
know what I look like and I know that
this is people are going to be tapping
in who might not know but I we put out
really good music bro and I'm solidified
bro like we've been here for a minute
I'm not expect to hear this right now no
thank you bro like you know hold on it's
Ralph he's like I didn't expect him to
sound like them like I'm telling you bro
about that [__] with G-Eazy was sick as
[__] I like the video thank you the fish
mouth move like this production in this
one nah you feel me yeah no that was
like the single when I was on the label
that was the big but like yeah now g-e's
the homie bro he's a good person too
like yeah real [__] that's good man I
like that one I just saw the I was
talking about the video yeah that one's
like the most Seattle [__] ever bro we
were in the stadium we were in the
Seattle
talked about cocaine so they weren't
[__] with it
the Park Place Market in Seattle you've
never seen that where they throw the
fish and [__] oh even about the
fisherman's War like The Wharf basically
it's not it's not called the word yeah
Place Market yeah you mean like the fish
may come and throw all that [__] that's
in Seattle yeah on YouTube all the time
yeah it's like a landmark no I just
thought people do that [__] I didn't
know it was like a bang over there not
hell yeah all right all right well dude
thank you so much for being here oh hell
yeah bro
this [__] was tight as [__] yeah this is
fun man uh hell yeah thank you bro Marty
got anything else
well I was just gonna ask we always ask
the people that are in music we're an
official Spotify podcast who's your top
oh yeah yes people that you've been
listening to man right now I'm running a
lot this V's album you [__] with V's
these yeah I think from Detroit I think
like and then I [__] with lucky you [__]
with lucky with I at the end right l u c
k i yeah I'm [__] his album Dominic
Fike just throughout the album so he
posted my Spotify reason yeah he's fire
even me and then like I listen to a lot
of Isaiah Rashad all right yeah that's
every shots j-i-d you know what I'm
saying like those are probably like my
top five right now like people I listen
to gid's [__] awesome yeah he's hard
bro he helps out with them and I play
this I opened for him back in the day
like in Seattle like back before he was
open for this guy named pale like it's
crazy bro like nobody knew who Jay was
it was wild he did that never song
though because I had been out it was
crazy that shit's sick as [__] live too
I saw him that was the last concert I
saw for [__] for real the shutdown no
I remember he did like the what you call
a check that on suck dick you know you
know I'm saying he did that and the
girls in the crowd was not [__] with
it and I was like nah that's hard bro oh
my God this is [__] and then eventually
it became like the dreamville [__]
yeah hit you know what I'm saying yeah
man she's hard bro yeah good that's a
good playlist that's a good playlist
right yeah so after this everybody
Travis Thompson on Spotify go check him
out all right thank you so much thank
you for having me bro appreciate this
has been uh fun as hell that gun was fun
I think I'm gonna bust that on a lot
more people yes please do I was dope
that was dope yeah why are you thank you
so much Travis Thompson thank you so
much for being here bro guys it's been
the dope's usual podcast we appreciate
you have a dope ass day yeah yeah good
[__] is that a good one yeah that was
fun I'm so sorry I don't gotta go
[__] do another interview
yeah
perfect
[Music]
foreign